navy officials in indonesia say
they have found items from the submarine
that went missing
last wednesday crushing hopes of the
crew's
survival the submarine had been
classified as missing but indonesia's
navy says
now it is officially declaring it a
sunken vessel
the sub's oxygen supply is believed to
have run
out early saturday several countries
sent warships and aircraft
to help with the search rescue crews
believe they have
located the submarine deep underwater
with no chance of survivors
for more on this i'm now joined by dw's
priyardani perba in jakarta priya darny
the navy held a press conference earlier
do they believe there are any survivors
first of all no one can guarantee if
there is any survivors
uh still alive or not and in that
press conference about an hour ago the
military commander
general hadith yanto has also
expressed his deep concern regarding
this
incident and his statement indicating
that
there is little hope for the crew
members
uh is still alive or not that's why the
nephi chief of stat has also said they
will keep
carrying out the rescue operation until
the ship was found whatever the result
may be
did they give any indication of what
might have happened to the vessel
well in that same press conference the
nephew chief of staff
admiral judo margona has said that
knowing that there are some parts of the
submarine were found uh it's not related
to
an explosion but more related to a crack
happening with that submarine so
it's related to a crack not an explosion
that's one thing but
they are currently investigating
investigating whether the submarine
is having some kind of electrical
failure but
it's still a speculation the negative of
staff
has also said that the previous
information about the oxygen supply
which has been said 72 hours
it's uh lasted seven to two hours
only if the submarine has black out but
uh again if the submarine has
a good electrical electric electrical
condition
he said that the oxygen supply will last
it
up until five days so it
certainly gave hope for this rescue
operation team to
find the survivor uh as soon as possible
here danny uh briefly uh the this story
no doubt has captured the nation
how are people reacting to this latest
development
yeah since the submarine were first
reported missing a couple days ago on
wednesday
people are expressing their concerns uh
just
about an hour ago i checked on twitter
there are
more more over 500 000 tweets expressing
their condolences about uh the latest
development
about this uh incident because it's
indicating that there's no hope
for the rescue operating team will find
the survivors
alive uh which believe have sung
under uh body warriors which believe
also have
depth more than 800 meters so it's
become a
national headline in our country and
people are
sending their prayers and also
condolences and also expressing their
thoughts
in twitter so yeah they are also um
giving supports for the search operation
team not only from military but also
from the police
and uh also give an appreciation for the
foreign countries that offers help
for the military to also help them to
rescue this the ship as soon as possible
dw's prior dhoni perba in jakarta many
thanks
thank you
you